Speaker 1: Jared Kushner, Donald Trump's son in
law, husband of Ivanka, appeared on Fox News.
He was asked about these documents that
Donald Trump stole and kept in his house.
And Jared Kushner played about as dumb as
I've seen anybody play this. This really
takes some skill to play this dumb.
Speaker 2: Leading political
opponent. This is a very serious it's a very
serious thing. I think that Americans on
both sides of the political aisle have some real
questions about what they did. There's a section
of the book where you talk about the Zelensky
transcript and you argued, Let's get it out there.
Let's just put it out there. So are you arguing
right now to your former boss and father in law,
you know, put out what these documents are,
put out what they're about in these in these
presidential documents. Tell everybody what's in
there. Well, I don't know whether he knows what's
in the boxes or not. Again, these were boxes
that were in storage. If you know, anyone knows,
Donald Trump knows, he keeps a ton of stuff.
They're always in boxes all over the place. And,
you know, who knows if they were things
that he did intentionally? Unintentionally.
Speaker 1: Yeah. He not only might he not
know what was there, those things maybe
were unintentionally there. Now, here it
comes. It's already getting it's stretching
credulity. But then it gets really weird.
Speaker 2: There's reports I've read that
the GSA packed the boxes. So like I said, I think
that right now what we want to know is what's in
the affidavit. I think that's the transparency
we should get to. But I do think President
Trump was probably one of the most transparent
presidents that we've had in a very long time.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, that's completely
untrue. Missing call logs from January 6th,
all sorts of obfuscation. People missing from
White House visitor logs. Arguably, again,
Democrats are going to do voter fraud. What
they meant was we're going to try to steal an
election. Trump was the most transparent,
really. Trump was the least transparent.
Speaker 2: And he sat for interviews
all the time. He was always asking,
answering questions to the press.
Speaker 3: You knew what he thought
of at 12:00 at night when he would
tweet, you know, what he thought at
six in the morning when he would tweet. Yeah.
Speaker 2: And so I know he doesn't. Lee is
often on the side of transparency. Have you
asked him if he knows what's in there or if he
went through them or if he intentionally kept
something back? When the FBI when the lawyer
said that they had already taken out everything
that was classified. I haven't asked him that,
but I have been with him since then and
he hasn't seemed too concerned about it.
Speaker 1: Right. One of the, as they love to say,
an unprecedented situation in presidential history
where a search warrant is served at the
president's home because of the documents he
stole. Jared acknowledges he's hung out with Trump
since, but they just haven't talked about this. It
just didn't come up, if you can believe that.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: And Martha. MACCALLUM. Okay. Okay.
Just accepting it. Martha MACCALLUM Should be
ashamed. Jared Kushner should be ashamed. But
again, this is happening on a network, Fox News,
where they just believe stuff. They believe
what they're told. They don't sit and think,
you know, these aren't really tough questions and
there's no follow ups. And Jared's explanation
makes no sense. Now they just go, let's listen.
They've just they've met. But Jared doesn't know.
He hasn't talked to Trump about it as his one of
his closest advisers from the entire presidency.
It simply didn't come up. They were talking
about golf and well-done steak and putting
ketchup on steak. That was really the only thing
they talked about. But on Fox News, the the
viewers just accept that they go, yep, that's
what it was. They talked about other things.